SIERRA: The Amazon is the biggest rainforest
in the world.
If we were standing in the middle of it right
now, we’d be surrounded by 2.5 million species
of insects.
The air would be thick with moisture, thanks
to 390 billion trees that exude gallons of
water every day.
All around us would be thousands upon thousands
of species of plants and animals, many hidden,
many yet undiscovered.
There is also something present that we can’t
see or feel.
An enormous repository of carbon that’s
been sucked out of the atmosphere and safely
stored away.
This place, The Amazon, is burning.
From the summer of 2018 to the summer of 2019,
more than 3,700 square miles of the Amazon
were destroyed - a thirty percent increase
from the previous year... and things have
only gotten worse since the Covid pandemic
began.
Without big changes soon, the Amazon as we
know it could be lost.
And the carbon could be released.
SKY NEWS: The Amazon Rainforest is on fire
again.
Whole mountains, hills, and valleys engulfed
in smoke.
PBS NEWSHOUR: Burning at a record-breaking
pace, sparking serious concerns around the
world.
TODAY: Scientists say we may have reached
a tipping point.
If just three percent more of the Amazon is
destroyed...
there will be no turning back.
SIERRA: I’m Gabrielle Sierra and this is
Why It Matters.
Today, the Amazon rainforest at a tipping
point, and the climate disaster that hangs
in the balance.
We read about fires in the Amazon, frequently.
So how are they started?
Are they sort of like the California wildfires
or is it something completely different?
LOVEJOY: So actually, they're quite different
from wildfires in other parts of the world
because the rainforest is wet.
SIERRA: This is Dr. Tom Lovejoy, a Senior
Fellow at the United Nations Foundation and
a professor at George Mason University in
Virginia.
He has worked in the Amazon since 1965, focusing
on scientific research, conservation, and
policy.
LOVEJOY: Lightning strikes don't start fires
in the Amazon, people start fires.
And to give you a sense, once somebody has
cut down some forest, they have to wait for
five days without a drop of rain before it
is dry enough to set fire to and get rid of
all this stuff that's between the firebrand
and turning it into some kind of agricultural
project.
SIERRA: Nine countries share the Amazon, but
roughly sixty percent of it is within Brazil’s
borders.
Which means they have a lot of control over
its fate.
And today, across this vast territory, small
groups of people are intentionally setting
fires in order to dry out the land for logging,
and to clear it for agriculture.
DE BOLLE: This way of clearing land for whatever
activity you want to do is very damaging to
the soil.
So what happens is that if later you want
to reforest that particular patch of land,
it becomes very hard to do because the soil
changes as soon as you clear it out because
it's now sustaining a different kind of environment
which is not rainforest-like.
And then you can't really grow a rainforest
back in that sort of setting.
SIERRA: This is Monica De Bolle, a senior
fellow at the Peterson Institute for International
Economics and a professor at the School of
Advanced International Studies at Johns Hopkins
University.
DE BOLLE: People refer to the Amazon a lot
as the lungs of the world, but that's not
really what the Amazon is.
What the Amazon does, is that it keeps a lot
of greenhouse gases from getting into the
atmosphere.
So it's not that the forest breathes for the
world, it's that once the forest is standing,
all of those greenhouse gases which are in
the soil, they're kept there, they're not
released into the atmosphere.
And as soon as you start cutting down the
forest, those greenhouse gases start to go
into the atmosphere - start to be released.
It's sort of like a climate bomb.
And as soon as you start cutting down the
rainforest, that bomb is released.
SIERRA: So how big is that carbon bomb?
Really big.
Scientists estimate that the Amazon stores
60 to 80 billion tons of carbon - or roughly
twice the total amount released from fossil
fuels in 2018 worldwide.
Losing the Amazon would accelerate warming,
with harmful impacts felt around the world.
DE BOLLE: The other issue is these hydrological
patterns.
So when we say that we're referring to the
rain cycles, and it's not just local, because
given the size of the Amazon, again, it creates
not just a microclimate, but a sort of macroclimate
within the whole of the South American region,
even affecting a bit of Central America as
well, given that the Amazon is so far north.
And so what happens is that the rain cycle
patterns as you cut down the forests, they
change, and sometimes they change really dramatically,
to the point where, you destroy people's lives
because they can no longer grow the crops
that they used to grow because the rain cycles
are completely different.
That has already happened in many parts of
South America that have felt this direct impact.
And this is only going to get worse, if the
deforestation continues.
SIERRA: Hydrology is the study of the movement
and distribution of water.
Because the Amazon is so large, and so wet,
its hydrology has a huge effect.
It supplies water to almost every country
in South America.
And, in fact, according to NASA, deforestation
has already been linked to reduced rainfall
in the region.
DE BOLLE: And then on top of all that, you
have the issue of Amazon tipping point.
So you get to a point where, if you go beyond
that point in terms of deforestation, the
rain forest is no longer self sustaining.
It's going to turn into savanna simply because
of the ecological dynamics of how rainforests
behave.
And there's a lot of concern that, where the
Amazon is right now is dangerously close to
this tipping point.
SIERRA: And as ominous as the climate bomb
and chaotic rain cycles sound, these wouldn’t
be the only global consequences of an Amazon
tipping point.
SIERRA: I'd like to sort of have a bit of
a broader picture.
What's at stake for the world when it comes
to the survival of the Amazon?
LOVEJOY: So what's at stake is that a significant,
probably the greatest concentration of terrestrial
biodiversity is in the Amazon, which by the
way is bigger than most people realize.
It's essentially equal to the 48 contiguous
United States.
So it's incredibly important in terms of biological
diversity and all that means for the future
of humanity and the future of nature.
SIERRA: He wouldn’t tell you this himself,
but Dr. Lovejoy is informally known as the
“godfather of biodiversity”.
In fact he coined the term in 1980.
It refers to the entire variety of life on
earth, and all the systems that make life
possible.
The Amazon, home to 10 percent of all species,
is kind of like the capital city of biodiversity.
SIERRA: Are there specific examples you can
point to that illustrate what humanity has
gained from the Amazon’s biodiversity?
LOVEJOY: Well, I would think that one that
would appeal almost to everybody in the world
is chocolate.
You know, I mean, cacao is native to the Amazon
and it was traded by indigenous peoples all
the way up into Mexico.
Another would be the ACE inhibitors, which
hundreds of millions of people in the world,
probably at least a billion people take every
day to control their high blood pressure.
And that all comes from understanding how
the venom of a nasty Viper actually works.
And at any point, something may be discovered
about the biology of a particular species
that turns out to have enormous practical
value.
One example would be what the indigenous people
use to stun fish, which is actually a vine,
and the molecule in it that does that is curare,
big, long complicated molecule too expensive
to synthesize.
So actually, every major abdominal surgery
in the world uses curare as a muscle relaxant.
SIERRA: The venom of a viper from a corner
of the rainforest led to a drug that is now
coursing through the veins of hundreds of
millions of people across the globe, helping
them combat heart disease, diabetes, kidney
disease, and even migraines.
And it’s impossible to know how many other
breakthroughs lie undiscovered in the forest.
LOVEJOY: So it's a library that most of the
books have not even been cataloged, let alone
read.
And so you need to think about all that biodiversity
as a whole bunch of species, every day, inventing
new solutions to biological challenges in
its natural history.
Any one of which if you pluck it off the shelf
and read it and understand it might have enormous
practical benefit.
So, to destroy the fundamental library for
the life sciences, is about as short sighted
a thing as humanity could possibly do.
SIERRA: To understand why the fires and destruction
have accelerated, it’s a good idea to take
a look back at the history of the Brazilian
Amazon.
DE BOLLE: It has always been pretty much a
no man's land in terms of regulation, in terms
of land rights.
And thus, it has been subjected over the past
several decades, to exploitation in various
ways.
In the 70s in the 80s, the Amazon was sort
of like the last frontier for development
in Brazil.
And so in large part, roads, big highways,
were built across the Amazon region and there
was a lot of deforestation that was done for
that, and after that development push, which
lasted a while, went away, then the cattle
growers came in and started deforesting some
areas and that was happening throughout the
1990s, and through the better part of the
2000s.
In 2004, that was the peak year of deforestation
in a very long time.
And at that point, the Workers Party which
was governing Brazil, and the environmental
minister that was in place then, Marina Silva,
decided to put in place a plan to stop or
to halt deforestation.
And so that government put together a strategy
to really reduce dramatically deforestation
and it was successful and they really enforced
environmental legislation.
They also put together a very good monitoring
system so deforestation fell by 80% in 10
years, as a result of these actions.
SIERRA: I mean, that's a lot.
So what happened after that?
DE BOLLE: Brazil then dove into a deep recession
in 2015 and 2016.
So these economic troubles basically meant
that all of these environmental concerns,
issues, policies that had been put in place,
they became sort of not as important given
the other challenges that the country was
facing, and therefore, from about 2015 or
so, we did start to see deforestation pick
up again, and that was because the government
was trying to cut spending, so it couldn't
spend on a lot of these agencies that were
responsible for monitoring and for enforcing
environmental legislation.
There were a lot of financing issues that
basically undid part of the effort that had
been done over those previous 10 years and
deforestation picked up again.
SIERRA: So it was a mix of just not having
the money anymore to enforce these new rules
to, you know, oversee these new policies,
but also people looking to make money from
the Amazon?
DE BOLLE: Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, that has always been a problem, because
what happens is that given a lot of distorted
incentives, regulations, lack of land rights
and things like that, the land in the Amazon
is actually worth more if it has no trees
on it, than if it still has rainforests standing.
SIERRA: And that’s because clearing rainforests
offers a quick dose of short-term profit.
The lumber itself can be sold, and once cleared,
the land can be used to raise cattle and other
livestock.
But economists like Monica note that this
is a backward way to value the land - when
compared to the potential profits of a discovery
like ACE inhibitors and the enormous cost
of climate change, these short term profits
are miniscule.
Still, they’re attractive to Brazilians
with few other options.
SIERRA: Can you give me a sense of the scale
of the current destruction?
DE BOLLE: Every year you can see how much
land is deforested.
So in 2015, it started to pick up; it was
broadly the same in 2016, picked up a little
bit more in 2017, 2018.
And then we hit 2019, and in 2019, two things
happen.
SIERRA: One, an exceptionally bad dry season,
which made the fires worse.
And two, the election of Jair Bolsonaro as
president.
Bolsonaro’s populist policies included an
emphasis on Brazil’s right to do whatever
it pleased with the Amazon.
DE BOLLE: Throughout the presidential campaign
and then afterwards when he was elected, he
kept saying that the Amazon resources should
be exploited, kind of using a military dictatorship
sort of argument that, you know, this was
the last frontier of development in Brazil.
So there were a lot of incentives from that
type of rhetoric for people to go in, do illegal
logging, start cutting down parts of the rainforest
to grow cattle and things of that sort.
So the combination of a more severe dry season
and longer dry season with, you know, a presidential
posture that was unlike that of previous governments,
led to a big increase in deforestation in
2019.
And we're seeing that again this year.
SIERRA: So who benefits from clearing the
land in the Amazon?
DE BOLLE: These are small players, they're
the ones that are benefiting.
Why is it not the big sort of agricultural
producers?
Well, because the big agricultural producers
in Brazil actually know they have a lot to
lose if they start cutting down the rainforest.
In fact the big agricultural producers in
Brazil have made a lot of effort in getting
sort of green seals, and you know, making
sure that whatever agriculture they practice
is environmentally friendly.
And this is what makes Brazil an agricultural
powerhouse and has made Brazil an agricultural
powerhouse over the years.
So we often see the Amazon issue being portrayed
in the media sometimes and blaming these big
producers.
The problem is not the big producers.
And in fact, they have been at the forefront
of trying to convince the current government
that, you know, it's just bad policy to deforest
the Amazon because it hurts agricultural exports
in Brazil.
SIERRA: This may sound surprising, but big
Brazilian companies have two strong motivations
to end the fires.
For one, global outrage is bad news for their
brands.
But perhaps more importantly, the domino effect
of the fires on the ecosystem threatens to
change weather patterns, which could make
it hard to grow soybeans, or other commodities
for export.
They’ve run the numbers, and the fires are
just bad for business.
Hearing all this, I sort of wonder about the
government's role in it.
Do you think it's fair to say that deforestation
and the fires are a policy decision by the
Bolsonaro Government?
LOVEJOY: So I would say, you know, de facto,
one has to conclude that, you know, if we
didn't have COVID right now, the fires in
the Amazon, which are worse than last year
would be the headlines.
And there's just a lot of inadequate economic
analysis that goes into the things that they
allow to happen.
But their, really, biggest fault is being
really weak on enforcement.
You know, six or seven years ago, the Brazilian
government was actually quite strong in enforcing
their environmental laws.
But budgets have been slashed, and wrong kinds
of signals have been sent.
SIERRA: What motivation does Bolsonaro have
to sort of allow this all to happen or even
to encourage it?
What type of leader is he, like, what are
his political motivations for allowing this?
DE BOLLE: So Bolsonaro is a president that
thrives on conspiracy theories, he thrives
on chaos.
He thrives on being anti-something.
And so the anti-environment cause for him
has been, to some extent, important because
he has managed to create a narrative that
polarizes and divides the country and helps
him politically.
On the Amazon specifically, he has no understanding
and no interest in understanding the implications
of cutting down the rainforest.
To just underscore that, his current environmental
minister is somebody who has absolutely no
experience in this area.
One thing that has happened in the Bolsonaro
administration, from the get go, this started
in the beginning, is that many of the agencies
that were involved in monitoring deforestation,
and enforcing environmental laws have been
stripped of their power to do so.
But also, many people, including scientists,
leading scientists in the country, were fired
from their jobs for criticizing the government,
with respect to its environmental policies.
SIERRA: Do you find that the argument for
this and the information that people need
to know about this gets trapped in this sort
of partisan space?
DE BOLLE: Brazil over the past several years
has become extremely polarized politically.
And so there are people who view environmental
issues as being something that we shouldn't
be talking about.
It's not relevant.
And there are other people who think they're
highly relevant.
And the way that this is split up in Brazilian
society is the people who don't view environmental
issues as being relevant are supporters of
the current government, and the remainder
are not.
And so that doesn't help things at all, because
then you don't get a debate.
Right?
And then you can't really get the points across
and even the science across, in telling people,
look, but here are the facts.
These are the facts.
If you cut down this rain forest to a significant
degree, it's gonna die out.
And if that happens, it's a disaster and it's
going to be a disaster for the country.
It's very difficult to make those points on
the basis of the existing science simply because
the issue has become so politicized.
SIERRA: Moving outside the political debate
in Brazil, there can be no doubt that the
loss of the Amazon would be an unmitigated
disaster for the rest of the world.
And with a problem that has such dire consequences
for everyone on Earth, you’d think the international
community would have some say on the issue.
But as a sovereign nation Brazil can do whatever
it likes with its Amazon.
Sovereignty is a word that gets used often
in international relations and not very often
anywhere else.
We’re going to take a quick break, but when
we return, a quick call with friend of the
pod Stewart Patrick, who just so happens to
be an expert on the concept of sovereignty,
and its friction with global problems like
climate change.
Hello listeners!
So if you dig all the questions we ask in
Why It Matters, you are going to love this
other podcast brought to you by our friends
at Pushkin Industries.
It’s called Solvable.
Kinda a natural fit.
Solvable is a weekly podcast where Malcolm
Gladwell, Anne Applebaum, and Jacob Weisberg
ask how we can find solutions to some of the
biggest issues of our time.
You’ll hear from David Baltimore on AIDS,
Sal Khan on basic education, and Roseanne
Hagerty on homelessness.
These problems can seem too big or too complicated
to fix.
But in the hands of the right people -- activists,
scientists, policymakers and politicians at
the top of their fields -- there are ways
to solve them.
And that’s the hopeful message of Solvable.
Listen and subscribe now in your favorite
podcasting app.
SIERRA: Hi Stewart!
PATRICK: Hey Gabby, how are you?
SIERRA: Good, how are you?
PATRICK: Doing well!
What are we talking about today?
SIERRA: So I have a question.
What is sovereignty?
PATRICK: Well, the concept of sovereignty
is basically the principle that every national
government has supreme political authority
over its territory and its inhabitants, as
well as what crosses its borders, and no other
country has the right to tell it what it can
do there.
So it's akin to a no trespassing sign globally.
But from an ecological perspective, the dilemma
arises that there's this big contradiction
between the international system, right, that's
the political world that's carved up into
193 different sovereign countries.
And the Earth system, which is a natural world
that obeys no such boundaries, right?
Now, the collision between these worlds is
most obvious in the case of global warming,
because the emissions that are released anywhere
in any country affect everybody.
They add to the planet's total.
But what if your territory contains something
that's so precious, that by exploiting it,
you're threatening the future of others.
Something like the Amazon, right, which is
a priceless repository of biodiversity, as
well as a carbon sink that we humans are relying
on to absorb a lot of that co2 we've been
pumping into the atmosphere, then things get
a lot more complicated.
And that's what's led to this controversy.
Is Brazil, the owner of its portion of the
Amazon rainforest?
Is it able to do what it wants to it?
Or is it only the Amazon's custodian with
an obligation to treat it with a level of
stewardship on behalf of all humanity?
So that's really the crux of this dispute.
Does the rest of the world have a say in what
Brazil and the other countries in the Amazon
basin actually do with their rainforest?
SIERRA: Okay so, the idea here is that if
something is on my land, I can do whatever
the heck I want with it.
But what if I decide to burn leaves on my
lawn, and the smoke makes my neighbor’s
kids sick?
I’d probably be hearing from the police
pretty quickly.
Climate change is similar, on a much bigger
scale, and it presents a conundrum for traditional
ideas of sovereignty.
Rising sea levels and soaring temperatures
do not obey borders.
Still old norms are hard to change.
What do you say to the claim that Brazil needs
to do this to better the lives of its own
people, potentially at the disservice of the
rest of the world?
DE BOLLE: So that argument makes no sense
to me.
Because there is no strategy.
This government doesn't have a strategy towards
developing the Amazon that we could say, ‘Oh,
this is good.’
‘Oh, this is bad.’
There isn't one.
There's simply a lack of a strategy and a
view that, you know, this is an argument that
the President has often made.
Oh, these are the poorest states in Brazil
and people deserve to use the Amazon as they
please.
So this is the sort of thing that we hear
but in the end, it makes absolutely no sense
because everybody loses including Brazil itself.
If cutting down the rainforest is going to
change the climate, the hydrological cycles,
all of these things that I talked about, and
given that Brazil is an agricultural powerhouse,
it's a very important agricultural exporter,
changing the hydrological cycle is going to
affect other crops.
It's going to affect the big soybean producers,
it's going to affect other types of agricultural
producers around the country, especially those
who are closest to the Amazon biome.
So it's not in the national interest at all
to make the sovereignty argument to allow
deforestation, it just doesn't make any sense.
SIERRA: So you feel like, you know, the claim
that this is lifting up Brazil's poor doesn't
hold any water...
DE BOLLE: Absolutely.
It's completely short term and short sighted,
it's not helping the poor at all.
It's not giving them anything.
And if you think about this in in a medium
term sense, if you are scrapping this natural
resource, which has a lot of benefits for
this population that's very poor, then what's
going to happen to them over the medium term
is that, you know, their living conditions
are going to become even worse.
SIERRA: So yes, Brazil can do whatever it
wants with the Amazon, based on its sovereign
rights.
But it’s not one of those classic sovereignty
problems in which what’s good for a single
country conflicts with what’s good for everyone
else.
The destruction of the Amazon isn’t even
good for Brazil.
What responsibility do you think that Brazil
has to the rest of the planet when it comes
to preventing climate change and preserving
biodiversity?
DE BOLLE: I think Brazil has a huge responsibility.
And what's sad, I think, is that previous
governments actually recognized that responsibility
and used it to increase Brazil's diplomatic
power.
Brazil is not exactly a diplomatic powerhouse
in the world.
But it did have this soft power when it came
to environmental issues.
It was very influential in putting together
the Paris Climate Agreement precisely because
it is a country that has all of these resources
and has this massive rain forest.
So previous governments knew how to use this
and use this in the right way, you know, with
the right perception.
Yes, we have the responsibility, and with
the responsibility comes this soft power that
we really do want to use.
This is a perception that's completely lost
on the current government.
The current government does not see Brazil
as having any kind of responsibility when
it comes to the rest of the world, nor does
it perceive this soft power as being important.
It just doesn't.
And so this kind of attitude has been undermining
to a very large extent, Brazil’s standing
in different fora around the world when it
comes to climate change and climate issues.
SIERRA: There has been some collective action
by the countries that share the Amazon.
In 2019, seven representatives met in Colombia
to sign the Leticia Pact, an agreement created
to address the issue of forest fires through
coordinated responses, including monitoring
and developing educational initiatives.
The pact also sought to increase the role
of the Amazon’s indigenous communities in
sustainable development.
But many other countries have remained silent.
Do you think this is an issue that should
be a priority for other countries?
LOVEJOY: You know, I think there's absolutely
no question about that.
The answer is yes.
This is too big a piece of how the climate
system works, and too big a piece of the biological
diversity of the planet for it not to be in
the interest of countries which can afford
it to contribute to improving the future trajectory
of what's going on there.
And that that's happened before in 1990, the
G7 meeting in Houston, basically launched
a program for the Brazilian rainforest, funded
through the World Bank.
It did a lot of good things, demarcated a
lot of the indigenous areas in Brazil, and
there's no reason that this kind of thing
can't happen again.
SIERRA: Is there a better way for the country
to benefit from having the Amazon there rather
than obviously just cutting it down?
DE BOLLE: Absolutely.
There's no lack of proposals to deal with
Amazon.
Over the last several decades, different environmental
ministers and other environmental activists,
NGOs, researchers, scientists, you know, there's
just so much material that's been published
on the Amazon, and how to deal with the problems
that the Amazon faces, and how do you actually
address, you know, these long standing issues.
I think that the main starting point for trying
to get things right in the Amazon is the land
registration and the land rights issue.
Until you sort that out, you can't sort anything
else out.
SIERRA: Clearing up land registration would
help end the Amazon’s no-man’s-land status,
and start the ball rolling toward a smarter
valuation of the land.
This means thinking about the long-term value
of the land’s biodiversity, rather than
it’s short-term value as cleared grazing
land.
LOVEJOY: So my dear friend and colleague Carlos
Nobre in Brazil has been talking about an
intact rain forest bioeconomy.
And yes, there are things you can do like
aquaculture, because some of the Amazon fish
could ultimately become as well known as salmon
or cod around the world.
But then there is a need for something which
Carlos calls the “MIT of the Amazon”,
which would be a Research Institute, which
is dedicated to developing some of these secrets
locked away in the biology and a really interesting
example could be to study leaf cutting ants.
These are ants that have colonies of maybe
a million, they will defoliate trees overnight.
And you see all the ants marching along with
little bits of green leaves.
Well, what they're doing is taking those down
into their nest where they have a giant underground
fungus farm.
And then they feed on the fungus, that's their
agriculture.
Well, for sure the ants have been able to
figure out which trees have natural fungicides
in their leaves, which it makes sense to leave
alone and not take down to the fungus farm.
So that could give you a direct way to find
a whole variety of new fungicides then can
be helpful in agriculture and other medical
applications to add to the ones that we already
have.
SIERRA: Fungicide may sound like small potatoes,
but it’s not.
In 2019 the global market for fungicides was
$12.3 billion dollars.
That's pretty cool.
I would definitely apply to go to the MIT
of the Amazon.
LOVEJOY: I think it could be a really exciting
place.
SIERRA: I mean, to put it a bit crudely, the
idea there is just stop cutting down the Amazon
and start patenting the technology that it
produces.
LOVEJOY: That's true and the other really
important thing to think about is how you
can have sustainable cities in the Amazon,
where people can have a reasonable quality
of life and do it without destroying the forest.
SIERRA: One of these cities already exists,
it is called Manaus.
It’s...amazing and you should probably Google
some images of it when you get a chance.
A thriving city deep in the Amazon, interwoven
with the trees.
It even hosted matches of Brazil’s World
Cup in 2014.
LOVEJOY: Most of the industry in Manaus is
actually assembly, and they assemble things
using materials that are not from the forest.
So the largest Harley Davidson factory in
the world is in Manaus.
Most of the computer boards and similar devices
for cell phones are assembled in Manaus.
So that's created economic opportunity and
the state of Amazonas, where Manaus is, has
an incredibly low deforestation rate because
opportunity is in Manaus.
I think most of the leaders of Amazon countries
want to see a sustainable future for the Amazon.
That's what they signed to agree to in the
Laticia Pact.
I think we know enough of the pieces of how
you could put that together, that a program
led by the Inter-American Development Bank,
which the Laticia Pact has asked for, could
actually make a serious difference.
And there are enough countries in the developed
world, I think of Norway in particular, who
are really interested in the future of the
tropical forests of the world and the Amazon,
who would be willing to contribute.
SIERRA: Are there any forms of progress that
you're hopeful about, you know, overarching
moves for change in this whole storyline?
DE BOLLE: What I'm most hopeful about is that
I do see that in the private sector in Brazil,
climate change and environmental issues have
become priorities.
By and large, the businesses in Brazil are
very worried about how the country is perceived
and how they, themselves, are perceived as
part of the country in sort of fighting for
these causes, climate change, environmental
problems, and all that.
So that I think brings an element of hope
because if there's another push from some
kind of engagement with other countries, the
private sector in Brazil would be largely
supportive of that.
Even if the government's doing nothing.
So, for example, when it comes to greenhouse
emissions, Brazil doesn't have, like the US
has, any sort of monitoring or anything like
that over greenhouse emissions but the companies
do it themselves.
They do it, and there's a private registry
of greenhouse emissions that's done by the
companies.
They report on their own on what they emit.
And so that's the part that makes me hopeful.
I mean, in spite of the inclinations of this
government, by and large, there's a perception
in Brazil's private sector, big companies,
small companies, medium sized companies, that
these are really important issues and that
you can't overlook them and that the future
of the country depends on them.
SIERRA: So there are reasons to be hopeful.
Many Brazilians understand the true value
of this land, to themselves and to the world.
Brazil’s industries understand it too.
And with the right international pressure,
the fires and deforestation could stop.
The problem is that the world is really distracted,
more distracted than at any time in recent
history.
And it remains deeply unclear whether that
pressure will actually materialize.
LOVEJOY: I think what it comes down to is
most of the people who are doing things don't
think that their increment is going to make
much of a difference.
But when you add it all up, it's at a global
scale.
So there's a real moment of reckoning going
on.
But now is the time to actually do something
about that and end up with a soft, sustainable
landing.
Global News: [protest chants] “ele não,
Amazônia sim!”
“not him [Bolsanaro], Amazon yes!”
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/Whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes.
Have a question or some feedback?
Want to just say hello?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you like the show, leave us a review!
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by Jeremy
Sherlick, Asher Ross, and me, Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria and our
intern is Senniah Mason.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Special thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff
Reinke.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you soon!